lisa foiles here at sunset overdrive
this is James he's going to tell us all
about this wacky colorful incredible
looking game do tell so sunset overdrive
is your awesome pakka lips be the
character you want to be customized
however you want a huge open world game
8 player co-op multiplayer that we're
showing here on the floor called chaos
squad it's a lot of fun crazy weapons
hopefully you saw the trailer during the
e3 press conference for Microsoft and
it's been a lot of fun to work on I did
okay so awesome paka lips that's that's
a word used yeah so you know we wanted
to we were bored of like the apocalypse
games or is dark and grey we're like you
know first rule was no rubble no rebel
in this game and we really wanted to
make a clean bright city and one of the
thoughts was well what would happen if
Iggy Pop was in the apocalypse he would
last like three days would they be the
best three days of your life so that's
what this games all about hyper agility
grinding on Rails running on walls
improvised crazy weapons like watching
tnt filled teddy bears and vinyl records
at people and just kind of enjoying and
surviving the city yeah I'm definitely
interested in the weapons this wide
variety of kooky weapon sir what can you
tell us about them we have eight here
today and we have a huge arsenal it's as
big an arsenal as we've ever made in one
of our games you've got great stuff like
the one-handed dragon which is sort of a
delayed firework weapon that launches
out these awesome fireworks there's the
high fidelity which fires out vinyl
records I've got the propane launcher
which fires literal propane tanks at
enemies for awesome explosions there's
the AK fu is your standard assault rifle
but in this game it also occasionally
will set off a nuclear explosion with
the giant boom and it like you saw on
the e3 demo so its up it's really a ton
of fun nice so this definitely seems
like a game that's more fun to play with
many people can you talk about the
multiplayer modes sure so we're showing
chaos squad which is our eighth player
cooperative multiplayer mode on the show
floor today and we're showing just the
end of it normally when you're playing
you're going to go into a photo booth in
the city when you're playing campaign
you'll take your campaign character
exactly as they are you'll pop right
into the multiplayer world on dedicated
servers and you'll go through a series
of missions in the open world with your
friends
and then you'll vote on those missions
you'll do them and then you get to the
main event this is like the kiss concert
the lights are out it's neon its
fireworks its pyrotechnics and you have
to defend your base from swarms of oddi
attacking them and you can lay some
traps out we've got crazy traps that are
like spinning blades like catapult
launchers pyro traps and you're going to
be like just fighting off these hordes
of enemies and if you survive you get
these awesome rewards that then you can
equip on your character and take right
back to your single-player game or you
can keep playing or chaos will this be
couch co-op or just online co-op just
online co-op cuz you got the hole open
world and the super graphical fidelity
wanted to look really awesome and but
you can again at any time when you're
playing single player go right into a
photo booth and get right into online
co-op so I want to talk about these
outfits the bunny ears and the crazy
costumes is that just part of the
customization or do those actually help
you in battle so those are all
customization what we didn't want to do
is like give you like oh I have to wear
this because it gives me like plus 10
health like that was really like you see
that in a lot of games it's like oh man
I don't really like that i wanna i only
want to wear it because i want the
ability from it so our costumes in the
game are just because they're awesome
wear what you want be what you want you
can play male you can play female
they're both fully voice through the
campaign multiple body types and every
clothing item in the game is
gender-neutral so wear whatever you want
there's no like female specific stuff or
male specific stuff it works on anybody
it looks good on anybody hairstyles
tattoos all that stuff we were really
really passionate about letting you play
the game is who you want to play as now
this seems like quite a departure from
your other games where did you pull
inspiration for this game I mean I think
there are some of our other games in it
there's some you know ratchet and clank
DNA there's some you know weapons
there's definitely a little resistance
you know with the coop but you know this
is like just our fever dream like
everything that we've been building up
to all of our previous games you know
all of our best ideas like everyone's so
excited at the studio i'm so passionate
about it and just getting like super
amped every day to come in and build
this thing and stay late and build this
thing that you know it's coming from
everyone movies i guess one of the big
ones was like you remember movies like
the omega man or i am legend like a
megaman charlton heston's driving the
big boat down the mt la streets or omega
man you're like hitting golf balls off
an aircraft carrier we like to that like
that'll be freaking awesome
yeah it's like so if the city's works
and everything's great and you're the
hero and you can do whatever you want
because it's the apocalypse that's
amazing and that's that's probably one
of the other big inspirations for the
game besides a pop kiss concert all that
thank you so much James there you go
guys sunset overdrive here at e3 2014